in this video
we're going to understand how to manage
a model repository on the hogging face
model hub
in order to handle a repository you
should first have a hugging face account
aiding to create a new account is
available in the description
once you're logged in you can create a
new repository by clicking on the new
model
option you should be facing a similar
model to the following
in the owner input you can put either
your own namespace
or any of your organization's namespaces
the model name is the model identifier
that will then be used to identify your
model on the chosen namespace
and the final choice is between public
and private
public models are accessible by anyone
this is the recommended free option as
this makes your model easily accessible
and shareable
the owners of your namespace are the
only ones who can update
and change your model a more advanced
option is
the private option in this case only the
owners of your namespace will have
visibility over your model
other users won't know it exists and
will not be able to use it
let's create a dummy model to play with
once your model is created comes the
management of that model
three tabs are available to you you're
facing the first one which is the model
card page
this is the page you used to showcase
your model to the world
we'll see how it can be completed in a
bit
the second one is the files and versions
your model itself is a git repository if
you're unaware of what is a git
repository
you can think of it as a folder
containing files which can be versioned
if you have never used git before we
recommend looking at an introduction
like the one provided in this video's
description
the git repository allows you to see the
changes happening over time in this
folder
hence the term versions we'll see how to
add files and versions in a bit
the final tab is the settings tab which
allow you to manage your model's
visibility and availability
let's first start by adding files to the
repository
files can be added through the web
interface thanks to the add file button
the added files can be of any type
python json text you name it
alongside your added file and its
content you should name your change or
comment
generally adding files is simpler when
using the command line
we'll showcase how to do this using git
in addition to git we're using git lfs
which stands for git
large file storage in order to manage
large model files
first i make sure that both git and git
lfs are correctly installed on my system
links to install git and git lfs are
provided in the video description
then we can get to work by cloning the
repository locally
we have a repository with a single file
the file that we have just added to the
repository using the web interface
we can edit it to see the contents of
this file and update these
it turns out i have a model handy that
can be used for sentiment analysis
i'll simply copy over the contents to
this folder
this includes the model weights
configuration file and tokenizer to the
repository
i can then track these files with the
get add command
then i commit the changes i'm giving
this commit the title of
add model weights and configuration
finally i can push the new commit to the
huggingface.co remote
when going back to the files and
versions tab on the web interface
we can now see the newly added commit
with the updated files
we have seen two ways of adding files to
a repository here
a third way is explored in the video
about the push to hub api
a link to this video is in the
description
unfortunately the front page of our
model is still very empty
let's add a readme markdown file to
complete it a little bit
this readme is known as the model card
and it's arguably as
important as the model and tokenizer
files in a model repository
it is the central definition of the
model ensuring reusability by fellow
community members
and reproducibility of results and
providing a platform on which other
members
may build their own artifacts we'll only
add a title and a small description here
for simplicity's sake
but we encourage you to add information
relevant to how was the model trained
its intended uses and limitations as
well as its identified and potential
biases
evaluation results and code samples on
how
should your model be used great for
contributing a model to the model hub
this model can now be used in downstream
libraries simply by specifying your
model identifier
you